>> Shannon: WE ARE AT A MOMENT
IN HISTORY AND THERE’S PLENTY OF
MISINFORMATION OUT THERE, SO WE
ARE TAKING YOUR QUESTIONS
STRAIGHT TO THE EXPERTS.
WE WILL BE DOING THIS EVERY
NIGHT, YOU CAN TWEET AT YOUR
QUESTIONS, TO @FoxNewsNight.
WE WILL TRY TO GET THEM
ANSWERED.
JOINING US NOT TO HELP THEM
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF JUST
CONNECT AT JEFFERSON HEALTH.
DR. JOHN HOLLANDER.
BOARD CERTIFIED MEDICAL DOCTOR,
NOW PART OF THE FOX FAMILY,
JEANETTE, GOOD TO BE WITH US,
DOCTOR, AS WELL.
>> THINK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Shannon: OUR FIRST QUESTION
COMES INTO US FROM TWITTER, CAN
YOU GET THE VIRUS FROM TOUCHING
THE GROCERY BAGS WHEN YOU SHOP
OR DON’T THEY CLING TO THAT TYPE
OF SURFACE?
I’M PARANOID THINKING ANY TO
WASH AFTER I TOUCH ANYTHING,
PLEASE ADVISE, THANK YOU.
I WENT GROCERY SHOPPING TODAY, I
WAS THINKING THE SAME THING.
>> YES, THAT’S A GREAT QUESTION.
IT IS POSSIBLE FOR VIRUS
BACTERIA, FUNGAL SUBSTANCES TO
LIVE ON INANIMATE SURFACES.
THE LIKELIHOOD OF PICKING IT UP,
HOWEVER, FROM A GARBAGE BAG -- A
CLEAN AVERAGE BAG OR GROCERY BAG
IS LOW, EVEN THOUGH IT’S
POSSIBLE.
IF YOU’RE MORE LIKELY TO PICK IT
UP FROM ANOTHER PERSON, FROM
COUGHING, FROM SNEEZING, FROM
WATER DROPLETS ENTERING FROM ONE
PERSON TO ANOTHER PERSON’S EYES
OR NOSE OR MOUTH, SO THAT’S MORE
COMMON TO PICK UP THE
CORONAVIRUS OR ANY OF VIRUS SUCH
AS THE FLU.
I STILL ADVISE IF YOU’RE GOING
SHOPPING AND YOU COME BACK TO
BRING IN A BAG OF GROCERIES, YOU
SHOULD STILL WASH HER HANDS.
>> Shannon: WHICH I DID AN END
SANITIZE THEM AS WELL.
DR. HOLLANDER, ANYTHING TO ADD
TO THAT ABOUT THE GROCERY
SHOPPING AND ALSO THE IDEA, I
DIDN’T KNOW WHAT TO DO BUT
PRODUCE BECAUSE IT WAS A LITTLE
BIT WORRIED ABOUT THAT TOO.
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK WE STILL
WANTED TO GO OUT SHOPPING, WE
STILL NEED TO GET FOOD.
I THINK THE DOCTOR’S ADVICE IS
PERFECT.
I WOULD JUST BE CAREFUL ABOUT
THE TIME YOU GO SHOPPING AND HOW
CROWDED IT IS TO BE SHOPPING AND
KNOW WHERE THE PEOPLE AROUND YOU
ARE IN THE STORE.
YOU’RE MORE LIKELY TO GET -- YOU
KNOW, TO CATCH A VIRUS FROM SOME
OF THE COUGHING SNEEZING ON OR
NEAR YOU AND WE SHOULD PRACTICE
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING THAT
EVERYBODY HAS HEARD ABOUT AND
TRY AND STAY 6 FEET AWAY FROM
EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> Shannon: I WAS LOOKING FOR
BANANAS AND I’M SORT OF DOING
THIS TURN TO THE SIDE FROM
EVERYBODY IS TRYING NOT TO TOUCH
EACH OTHER AND KIND OF, YOU
KNOW, MOVE THEIR WAY AROUND
WITHOUT GETTING IN ANYONE’S
PERSONAL SPACE.
DR. HOLLANDER, I WILL START WITH
YOU ON THIS NEXT ONE.
IF THIS VIRUS IS HAVING ALMOST
NO EFFECT ON PEOPLE UNDER THE
AGE OF 50, WHY ARE WE CLOSING
EVERYTHING DOWN?
SHOULDN’T OUR FOCUS INSTEAD BE
ON THE ELDERLY AND VULNERABLE
INSTEAD OF THIS SWEEPING
RESPONSE THAT HURTS EVERYONE?
>> NO, THE SWEEPING RESPONSE IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE YOU CAN GET THE VIRUS
AND YOU CAN PASS THE VIRUS ON IT
WHEN YOU ARE ASYMPTOMATIC.
YOU MIGHT BE A 2-YEAR-OLD THAT’S
REALLY UNLIKELY TO HAVE SIDE
EFFECTS BUT IF YOU GO TO YOUR
GRANDPA’S HOUSE, THEY CAN GET IT
AND IT CAN BE REALLY SERIOUS FOR
THEM.
IT CAN BE REALLY CRITICAL TO
STOP THE SPREAD EARLY ON BECAUSE
THE PERSON WHO IS CONCERNED
ABOUT GETTING IT MAY TRANSMITTED
TO A REALLY HIGH RISK PATIENT IN
THE NEAR FUTURE.
>> Shannon: DR. ?
>> ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
IT EVEN THOUGH WE SEE MOST OF
THE ILLNESSES IN OUR OLDER
POPULATION WITH UNDERLINED
MEDICAL DISEASE, YOU CAN STILL
BE, IN YOUR 30s OR 40s OR
EVEN YOUR 50s AND STILL END UP
IN THE HOSPITAL.
I’VE SEEN THAT HAPPEN AND
ESPECIALLY IF THE YOUNGER
POPULATION ARE SMOKING OR VAPING
OR NOT TAKING CARE OF
THEMSELVES.
SO WE ARE ALL AT RISK EVEN
THOUGH THERE’S A HIGHER RISK IN
THE OLDER POPULATION.
>> Shannon: IT DOESN’T JUST
MEAN IF YOU’RE UNDER THAT AGE
LIMIT YOU’RE GOING TO BE FINE,
BECAUSE WE’VE ALL SEEN AND READ
ABOUT THOSE CASES.
OUR NEXT ONE COMES FROM KENNY
BYRD.
QUESTION, IF YOU HAD THE
CORONAVIRUS, CAN YOU GET IT
AGAIN AND CAN YOU HAVE THE FLU
AND THE CORONAVIRUS AT THE SAME
TIME?
DR. HOLLANDER?
>> SO WE HAVE NOT HAD
CORONAVIRUS AROUND LONG ENOUGH
TO KNOW, BUT I THINK MOST PEOPLE
SUSPECT THAT THIS TYPE OF
CORONAVIRUS, ONCE YOU HAVE IT,
YOU PROBABLY WON’T CATCH THIS
CORONAVIRUS AGAIN.
KIND OF LIKE THE FLU.
IF YOU WON’T GET THE SAME FLU A
SECOND TIME, BUT IT WILL BE
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT NEXT YEAR AND
YOU CAN BE PRONE TO IT AGAIN.
IT IS THEORETICALLY POSSIBLE TO
HAVE THE CORONAVIRUS AND THE
FLU, BUT THAT IS INCREDIBLY
UNLIKELY SO ONE OF THE TESTING
ALGORITHMS THAT WE WIDELY USE IS
THAT IF YOU TEST POSITIVE FOR
THE FLU, WE DON’T GO ON TEST YOU
FOR CORONAVIRUS BECAUSE YOU
THINK IT’S SO UNLIKELY THAT YOU
HAVE IT.
>> Shannon: DR. NESHEIWAT,
SEEMS LIKE YOU, SAME PROTOCOL?
TO GO EXACTLY.
IF A PATIENT COMES IN AT I SWAP
THEM -- FOR EXAMPLE, I JUST HAD
THIS LAST WEEK, TESTED POSITIVE
AND WE STOPPED RIGHT THERE.
PUT HIM ON SOME ANTIVIRAL
MEDICINES.
I STILL SAID, LOOK, YOU NEED TO
GO HOME AND REST AND WE TOLD HIM
TAKE AT LEAST A WEEK OFF ONCE
YOU BETTER COME ANOTHER DAY OR
TWO AND THEN GO BACK TO WORK
WHEN YOU’RE COMPLETELY A
SYMPTOMATIC WITHOUT FEVER.
>> Shannon: OKAY.
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE THERE’S
GOING TO BE A LOT OF DOWNTIME
BECAUSE THAT’S JUST THE WAY IT’S
GOING TO BE FOR A WHILE.
ERIC COLEMAN WRITES IN THE TEST
DETECT CORONAVIRUS YOU HAVE
SYMPTOMS OR ONLY AFTER A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF TIME HAS PASSED WITH
THE DISEASE?
DR. NESHEIWAT, WE WILL START
WITH YOU BECAUSE I KNOW THAT --
IT SEEMS LIKE THE ONLY WAY YOU
WOULD GET TESTED A
SYMPTOMATICALLY IS IF YOU HAD A
FAMILY MEMBER OR SOMEBODY THAT
WAS ALREADY CONFIRMED TO HAVE
CORONAVIRUS, BUT I HAVE HEARD OF
THESE PEOPLE WHO NEVER HAD ANY
SYMPTOMS BUT HAD A FAMILY
MEMBER, SO THEY WERE TESTED AND
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE TESTED AND
THAT WERE A SYMPTOMATICALLY DID
HAVE CORONAVIRUS.
>> YEAH, SO IT’S POSSIBLE TO
ABSOLUTELY TEST POSITIVE AND BE
A SYMPTOMATIC.
SOME PEOPLE MAY HAVE SUCH MILD
SYMPTOMS THEY MADE NOT REALIZE
WAS GOING ON BUT USUALLY YOU
WOULD SEE SOMEONE WITH A FEVER
AND RUNNING NOSE, COUGH,
SHORTNESS OF BREATH.
THEY MIGHT BE MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE A POSITIVE -- A CLEAR
POSITIVE EARLIER, BUT IT’S
DEFINITELY POSSIBLE TO TEST
POSITIVE AND HAVE NO SYMPTOMS.
WE ARE ALREADY SEEING THAT WITH
MANY PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, EVEN FOR EXAMPLE, WE
SAW SOME RECENT BASKETBALL
PLAYERS WHO WERE ASYMPTOMATIC
BUT WERE EXPOSED TO SOME OF
THEIR TEAMMATES AND WENT AND HAD
TESTING OUT OF AN ABUNDANCE OF
PROGRESSION BECAUSE THERE WAS
CONCERN THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
SPREAD IT TO HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF OTHER PEOPLE.
>> Shannon: OKAY,
DR. HOLLANDER, THAT’S WHEN I
THOUGHT WAS VERY INTERESTING, I
HADN’T THOUGHT ABOUT THIS, THIS
COMES IN FROM ROXIE, WHO SAYS
ANY ADVICE WE ARE EXPECTING
MOTHERS?
SHOULD THEY BE CONSIDERING A
MIDWIFE OR WILL THE HOSPITAL BE
OKAY TO HANDLE THE DELIVERY?
THANKS.
>> SO I THINK AT THIS POINT IN
TIME WE ACTUALLY FORTUNATELY
DON’T KNOW OF ANY ADVERSE
OUTCOMES ON PREGNANCY.
IT DOESN’T APPEAR THAT THERE IS
A HIGHER RATE OF MISCARRIAGE.
IT DOESN’T APPEAR THAT THERE’S A
HIGHER HIGHER RATE OF
COMPLICATIONS.
AND IT DOESN’T APPEAR THAT THERE
IS A HIGHER RATE OF FETAL
ANOMALIES.
SO WE THINK PREGNANCY CAN
PROCEED JUST LIKE PREGNANCY
WOULD WITH OTHER CONDITIONS
WHERE WE WANT MOM TO STAY WELL,
WE WANT MOM TO BE HYDRATED, WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT MOM FEELS
OKAY AND ISN’T SICK AND
DEHYDRATED, BUT IN TERMS OF WHEN
DELIVERY COMES, WE DON’T KNOW
ANYTHING DIFFERENT THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE.
>> Shannon: OKAY.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS A LITTLE
BIT LAST WEEK, THE THOUGHT THAT
PLASMA, AT LEAST IN SOME
PLACES -- WORKED TO USE PLASMA
FROM PEOPLE WHO WERE FULLY
RECOVERED ON PEOPLE WHO WERE
THEN SUFFERING FROM, IS PLASMA F
RECOVERED COVID-19 PATIENTS
EFFECTIVE IN TREATING CURRENT
INFECTED PATIENTS?
DR. NESHEIWAT, ANY NEWS ON THAT?
>> IT’S CALLED PASSIVE ANTIBODY
THERAPY AND ANYTHING WE CAN TRY
AT THIS POINT TO TRY TO KEEP
PATIENTS ALIVE AND WELL AS A
LAST RESORT WHILE IT’S STILL
UNDERGOING TESTS, I’M ALL FOR
IT.
SO IN THEORY IT COULD HELP
BECAUSE WHAT YOU’RE DOING IS
TAKING THE BLOOD FROM SOMEONE
WHO HAS RECOVERED FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS, SO USUALLY WHEN YOU
HAVE AN INFECTION, YOUR BODY CAN
CREATE WHAT’S CALLED ANTIBODIES,
WHICH CAN PROTECT YOU FROM
FUTURE INFECTIONS, SO THAT’S THE
THEORY BEHIND IT, USING A
PROTECTIVE MECHANISM, INJECTING
IT INTO PATIENTS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY SYMPTOMATICALLY AND
CURRENTLY TRYING TO FIGHT THE
VIRUS TO SEE IF THEY CAN HAVE
SOME RELIEF AND RECOVERY FROM
IT.
SO I THINK IT’S HOPEFUL IN
ADDITION TO THE CURRENT
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE BEING TRIED
RIGHT NOW.
>> Shannon: OKAY, AND OUR LAST
QUESTION TO YOU, DR. HOLLANDER,
AS A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER, I’M
CURIOUS IF WHEN WE ARE EXPOSED
TO A KNOWN COVID-19 PATIENTS,
WILL WE HAVE TO SELF QUARANTINE?
IF THE HOSPITALS GOING TO BE
HAVE TO BE PUT OUT FOR 14 DAYS
AFTER EXPOSURE WE WILL QUICKLY
HAVE NO ONE TO CARE FOR
PATIENTS.
THOUGHTS?
>> YEAH, SO THAT IS A REAL, REAL
BIG PROBLEM AND I’M GOING TO
ADDRESS THAT IN A LITTLE BIT A
ROUNDABOUT WAY, WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHY AS YOU INTRODUCED ME MY
TITLE HAS TO DO WITH
TELEMEDICINE.
WE DON’T WANT PEOPLE WHO ARE TOO
SICK TO COME TO THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT AND WE DON’T WANT
PEOPLE WHO AREN’T SICK TO COME
TO URGENT CARE CENTERS OR
PRIMARY CARE OFFICES BECAUSE WE
WANT TO DECREASE SPREAD.
SO ONE OF THE WAYS WE CAN
MAINTAIN THE WORKFORCE IS HAVING
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SICK STAY
HOME AND GET TESTING AND WHAT WE
ARE DOING AT OUR SHOP IS WE
ACTUALLY HAVE PEOPLE CALLING,
THEY WILL SEE A DOCTOR LIKE ME
LIKE YOU SEE ME ON TV RIGHT NOW,
I’LL BE BE ABLE TO EXAMINE YOU
AND I’LL BE ABLE TO START YOU UP
FOR TESTING IN A SECURE
ENVIRONMENT WHERE YOU DON’T
EXPOSE IT TO OTHER PEOPLE AND
THAT WILL PRESERVE THE
WORKFORCE.
>> Shannon: I THINK WE WILL
SEE A SPIKE IN TELEMEDICINE,
THAT MAY BE ONE OF THE NEW
THINGS AS A FOLLOW-UP TO THIS.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR TIME AND